tassia harlan we're here today for the
letter kenny spin-off shorzy now for
those who may be sort of lapse fans or
have taken a bit of break between these
two spin-offs or maybe hopefully a lot
of new fans can you sort of break down
for the uninitiated what the premise of
this letter kenny spin-off is
yeah well shorzy is a
chirping
mother-loving
ruffian hockey player
and he is
you know playing in a team learning
elite called the no show with it which
is the northern ontario senior hockey
organization
and uh he's we're trying to revive a
team and bring it up bringing it back up
to getting some wins so
do we do we finally get to see shoresies
face after all these years
yup
i wonder who it could be
i wonder
um can you touch a little bit about each
of your roles in this
uh well saying when ed he's um
he starts off like as a hockey player
with um and then like you know stuff
happens
um someone gets canned and then he ends
up becoming the coach
and um it's actually great because he
looks like he looks he looks to shoresie
for like advice and like giving him
pointers because saying why he's like a
shy and reserved guy sure as he's
helping him like come out of the shell
yeah sure as he is not a shy and
reserved guy
in fact i play nat who is the manager of
the team and keeping shorzy in line
is part of the
mission and the task at hand and you
know um
part of her troubles
who is
among the cast and i mean this in a
positive way in a fun loving way who is
the hardest to keep in line on set
on set i'm the one who's usually so
distracted talking to everyone and i
need someone constantly reminding me hey
shaq you're supposed to grab this you're
supposed to do that
i mean i'd say me but
i was gonna say i'm not i'm gonna point
the finger
when we're on set but i try to stay
focused because we move quickly yes yes
well i appreciate that uh self-awareness
i think it's a great feature um
i i i now i can't i have no experience
in this regard but i can imagine you
know sometimes when you're working on a
new project a pilot um there's a lot of
uncertainty is it gonna get picked up is
it gonna click with an audience for you
two how does it feel to get involved
with a spin-off when there is a
pre-existing audience perhaps with some
preconceived notions or expectations for
what the show's gonna be
well it's a little like um i don't wanna
say like worrisome because that just
makes it sound like a negative thing but
like it's just
we know there's expectations that are
gonna like people are like okay it's
obviously litter kenny some people
already see that they're disappointed
that they're seeing uh shorzy's face and
um
but you know um the whole letter kenny
vibe is there and we bring some new um
things to the table as well like even
just our characters
yeah ourselves yeah there's definitely
big shoes to fill
and so that is hanging in the air but
we're in such good hands jared and jacob
do such a good job of
you know keeping things together and
they're so good at what they do and we
saw some of the episodes some of the
footage and it's just really really
funny and really fun so i'm really
excited to share it
since we have two actors here you know
one with a lot more experience than the
other i am curious for each of you how
does it feel to see yourself on camera
have you both grown comfortable with it
now is it still sometimes a little
awkward because i know some actors
really never get over that part
i love seeing myself on camera
that's what i'm talking about
straight up
i'm a little bit above like i like it
depends it depends on my mood i guess
yeah yeah
um harlan have you noticed in your
experiences um
uh industry-wide shift at all when it
comes to opportunities for indigenous
talents from my perspective sometimes
you know you see
hollywood and hollywood north sort of
diversifying and maybe you think it's
more caught up than it actually is have
we come far enough when it comes to
giving indigenous talents opportunities
and how much further do you think we
need to take it well honestly i think
it's like it's it's getting there for
sure like it's like right around the
corner for like more because um
like me i had i played uh i'm korea
myself
and like
um i played a character uh like other
i've just played other um indigenous
peoples before right and i want
hopefully one day in the future that
those people can represent themselves
you know so like if an ojibwe person was
to be an ojibwe person or like you know
me to be like a creepy person in the
next film or tv show or whatever like
that's what i really want because right
now we just got like different nations
representing others like playing a
different um
tribe i guess
yeah yeah well there's no shortage of
talent so i i hope that day is coming
soon and sooner
um
is it okay if we touch on ukraine a
little bit absolutely yeah so i know
your mother is of ukrainian descent um
how do you feel at this stage i know
sometimes
people uh may sort of feel overwhelmed
when something is going on as long as it
has been how do you feel about the
ongoing conflict and sort of the global
response to russia's aggression well
it's it's just wild because i remember
exactly where i was when i heard that
russia invaded because before it was
just kind of looming and i remember i
called my mom and my family immediately
and you have this visceral reaction that
just kind of
happens and i was you know upset of
course and
it stayed with me and then i got to
thinking how can i
help and what can i do so i did you know
i'm working with some people to do
fundraising campaigns and stuff like
that but
i think that there just can be more
action from the international community
you know we can't just be invading other
countries with no response and i think
that we
have the resources to step it up and i
think that we should because
that's what we do as a global community
you know
okay well thank you both for touching on
those things i do want to finish off
here if i let you go on some lighter
stuff have a little bit of fun you guys
ready for a bit of rapid fire
okay yes okay let's do this uh to both
of you who on the shores set makes you
laugh the hardest
jake
competitive field i'm sure but i like
the unanimous call there uh tassia your
parents reaction to your to you finger
painting on the bedroom walls was what
no
it was just like
of course you know
of course you're doing this
well you know you got to have a good
creative outlet i think if they look
back on it it all led to great things uh
harlan what is the through line between
acting and performing music because we
see some great great musicians make the
transition into acting and i know you
saw you yourself has been forming on
stage for a really long time
there's like no difference you know
there's um there's people in the
audience and there's people behind the
camera like there's more than 10 people
and um
just putting on a show i guess you know
as a mission not just stand there and
play the guitar you know do a little bit
of moves here and there but yeah i think
it transitions pretty well into acting
amazing um now i know specifically tacia
has lived just about every everywhere in
canada um you've
traveled to and far and i'm sure harlan
your work takes you around canada as
well i would like your best secret gem
restaurant or if you're not a foodie any
sort of any sort of shop or place in
general that you like to visit
rosie's in sudbury oh good one
i would say the mckenzie room in
vancouver
and the laughing beaudette in sudbury
amazing well i am in vancouver so i have
a spot to check out this weekend so
thank you very much for that uh guys
thank you so much for your time today
you star alongside jared quiso in
shorezi the letter kenny spin-off
premiering may 13th if there's anything
you want to let the people know the
floor is yours
hit us up online for questions we are
around we're all going to be celebrating
together and watching the drop of the
show so um ask as many questions as you
want we are here we're so excited for
everyone to see it what she said